let's bring in the president of finland
sauli ninas day mr president thank you
for the time
thank you
you share a long border with russia if
you look at the map you could draw
almost a perfect triangle to moscow kiev
and helsinki
how do you see the last eight nine days
of course like i guess all of us
we are very surprised something almost
impossible has taken place
no one could have
imagined that in europe
in
2020
something like this would happen and it
seems to continue
it is
it's a tragedy
you had a meeting today with president
biden in the oval office
how did you take that meeting and what'd
you take away from it we discussed uh
quite a lot not only
of the current situation in in ukraine
we talked also about russia about china
but also from the
nordic countries
and how do we take this do you want to
join nato now
yeah
well
we have a change situation in
both in
finland and sweden
for the first time we see that maturity
of people
are pro
according to the polls
and this is something we are now
opened a
discussion with our parliament
we try to define
all the
circumstances
all the risks and all the benefits
and doing that quite efficiently as soon
as possible
mr president there's an article in
atlantic uh the atlantic council it says
will finland and sweden join nato now
i'll quote from that for finland the
shadow of history is always present an
833 mile long border with russia means
that finland knows it can never take its
sovereignty for granted finns haven't
forgotten soviet demands on their land
and harbors in 1939
while secretly preparing for an invasion
which moscow launched in november of
that year there is a lot of history
that maybe will lean you now considering
what's happening
towards getting into nato
yes
back to 1939
except that russia attacked
we
protected and defended our country they
didn't come in
one has to remember that and surely that
um reminds the situation in ukraine at
the moment you have to remember also
that finland has
maybe
behaving a bit differently than european
many european countries we have all the
time
we have been very keen on developing our
own defense forces which are quite
strong ones
so
that's one element uh
protecting us and uh
european union
is now maybe more united than ever we
see also germany taking strong position
on defense sector
that means that also europe will cover
more security and the third element
surely is
membership of nato and like i said
that is under discussion in finland
you already spend more than two percent
of your gdp on defense forces you
mentioned germany
russian president vladimir putin talked
to the chancellor of germany today
according to the readout he denied that
russian forces are bombing ukrainian
cities
i want to ask you about vladimir putin
you've met him a number of times you've
had a lot of meetings many more perhaps
than other leaders in the region
have you noticed a change in putin
if you follow his speeches and
opinions during the decades
he has always showed some kind of
bitterness and
even hatred
because
he has said mother russia has been
mistreated and this kind of an attitude
has increased year after year
now that
we all have seen how in a way lonely he
seems to be and
makes a big distance to other people
it's not maybe best possible for a
person to
live only with his bitter and
hate
that might increase
in his uh thinking
so knowing please kind of change maybe
maybe he has
do you think that he will expand beyond
ukraine
he has done already so far something
that we considered
as impossible
and it's very difficult to predict what
he's going to do next but now it seems
that he's going forward and destroying
ukraine
last thing mr president the nato
secretary general has said
that nato warplanes will not do a no-fly
zone
we understand the desperation
but you also
believe that if we did that
we'll end up with something that could
end in a full-fledged war in europe
involving many more countries
i assume you agree with that
but where do you think this is going
surely it's a nato decision
but
i understand that
now
everybody wants to
avoid more escalation
which is all the time very nearby there
might be even accidental
deeds which suddenly
break out and
if we have escalation we have
a huge war in front of us so
trying to safeguard
that i think is the reason
why nato is not present
president of finland uh mr president we
really appreciate your time on special
report
thank you so very much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else